Twelve things introverts
might find difficult by Samantha Chavez
As introverts, we sometimes find mundane tasks
more challenging than your average extroverts
While introvert's experiences might be similar
We all differ in the way that we deal with them
Here are 12 things that an introvert might find difficult
1. Being told not to be shy
Throughout our life, us introverts will often hear
People tell us to "stop being shy"
Thus, us associating shyness with weakness
People tend to confuse the two.
Even though there's nothing wrong with shyness.
Discovering introversion helps us rationalize how we feel.
Making it easier for us to move around
in social situations.
Still, most introverts will avoid explaining their introversion
To someone they've just met (can't blame them)
In hopes of stopping the "Don't be shy" comments, altogether.
2. Writing formal emails.
This can be a prime source of anxiety for introverts.
There will be at least 3 sessions of
drafting, revising, and editing alone
Before they feel comfortable enough to press send.
And even then, we are not safe from
Number 3.
Overthinking Little Things
This translates mostly to face-to-face interactions.
As we have little to no time
to prepare for what we are going to say we fear that we will
make a mistake, or spill something that we shouldn't.
Furthermore, a single phrase during a conversation can
plague our minds for the rest of the day.
Even if the other person didn't think much of it.
Not to mention, number 4.
4. Reasoning Doesn't Make It Better
This goes along with face-to-face interactions.
It's a very distressing experience for introverts.
Even if it seems minor.
Sometimes, we're even aware how minor it is.
And that the other person has probably forgotten about it already.
This doesn't stop the dark cloud looming above us
telling us we did wrong, though.
5. The Idea Of Social Engagements.
"There is going to be a big gathering!"
Are words that an introvert dreads to hear.
We need time to prepare mentally. For this reason,
it's important for us to be informed of the time and place
of the party, as well as the number of people that are attending.
Make it the least vague possible,
and you'll be sure to lessen an introvert's anxiety.
6.Cancelled Plans
Trust us when we say that we have already accepted the fact that
we were going to attend a social gathering.
We can't help the anxiety we feel the days
prior to it, though. Hearing about
cancelled plans is an introvert's joy.
Since it's relieving the lead-up anxiety.
7. Navigating Social Events
Sometimes, we aren't so lucky as to have plans cancelled.
And upon arriving to a social event, we'll do our best
to get the greetings over with, so we can find a secluded
corner in which we can spend time observing,
rather than participating.
It doesn't mean we're alone, though.
It means we want to stay with people we trust/won't
force us out of our comfort zone.
8. Sadly, It Doesn't Always Work out
Maybe,
we don't find the people we're most comfortable with at the event
and any attempt at conversation results in us getting
pushed further aside, if we fail.
This can take a toll on introverts,
and exhaust them within seconds.
This leads us to number 9.
9. Attempting and Failing at Conversations.
When we are discouraged from speaking
because we tried, and weren't heard,
we'll often end up blaming ourselves for even trying.
10. Bad Days
On particularly bad days, it's hard for an introvert
to find motivation to speak to ANYONE.
This might be difficult to understand, and often cause friction
with an introvert and their friends.
11. Restlessness and Self-Disgust
During our bad days, we look for ways to
channel our dissatisfaction with ourselves, either by cleaning
or being creative.
We don't really want to talk to anyone yet,
but we still need a sign of reassurance.
We simply look to distract ourselves.
12. being told to act "normal"
Althought introverts
prefer to listen instead of participate
in conversations, it's common for their silence to draw attention
And more often then not,
It tends to be of the negative time.
This can lead to unwanted comments telling us to
"act normal". Thus, making us more exhausted.
While introverts might share certain experiences,
they all affect us differently.
What are some things that you find difficult as an introvert?